وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا تستمر المعارك الطاحنه بين
الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني في مختلف
الجبهات لسيمه جبهه اقليم دومباس ومع دخول
فصل الربيع اليوم افاد مصدر عسكري روسي
مطلع ان نحو 100 الف جنديا اوكراني
ومدرعات وعتادا واسلحه تحشدهم لشن هجوم
مضاد في موعد اقصاه مايو القادم على
القوات الروسيه هذا وتتواصل عمليه الدعم
العسكريه الغربي الى اوكرانيا واخرها
تاكيد المقدونيا الشماليه تسليمها اربع
مقاتلات من نوع سو 25 الى سلاح الجو
الاوكراني
في غضون ذلك قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيقدم مليون قضيه
مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملي مترا للجيش
الاوكراني من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني
ان دعم الفوريه والمستمره لمواجهه ما وصفه
بالعدوان الروسي سيغيروا قواعد اللعبه وفق
تعبيره